Romania joined fully and wholeheartedly
the effort of turning solidarity Lanes
into a true success story
we invested significant efforts
financial and human resources into new
infrastructure new or upgraded border
crossing points 24 7 Services as well as
additional storage facilities
these efforts continue only yesterday we
opened a new border crossing point at
our border with Ukraine the first opened
by Ukraine with an EU member State since
the start of the war
I am proud of the steps Romania took
which allowed the transit of over 6.5
million tons of grains from Ukraine an
essential contribution to Global Food
security
this is only the beginning of a long
journey
solidarity Lanes should turn from a
temporary emergency solution into a
long-term connectivity between the
European Union and Ukraine and the
Republic of Moldova in view of their
future accession
this is why we supported the initiative
of extending the 10 t as well as the
financing of projects for improving
transport connections
the Romanian courts of galatz and
constanza are prepared to play an
increased role in this respect
we thank the European commission for the
significant efforts invested in the
solidarity Lanes and will remain engaged
working closely to take forward the best
solutions for Ukraine the Republic of
Moldova Global Food security and supply
chain stability thank you